Levon Aronian becomes the only player in
history to win the World Cup for the
second time in tbilisi magnus carlsen
wins his first classical tournament in
more than 14 months at the isle of man
international and both players have
their love life thrust into the
spotlight of the chess world this month
because one of them put a ring on it
we talked speech Chess Championship
previews best in worst moments blunders
brilliance sees the whole lot it's the
show with more potential than leonid
Stein in the 1960s it's chess Center
[Music]
he's the closest thing the chess world
has to a professional sports broadcaster
so we bring him on when it's time to
make predictions
Robert Hess you broke down the first
round of the speech Chess Championship
for us and you were pretty accurate how
do you see the second round going
starting with the matchup of MDL vs.
Sascha Grisham well Danny we got to go
with the lovable Frenchman not only does
he have experience with giant bullet
chess but he's a very experienced in
chess calm as well and he beat gros
shook in the World Cup in the rapid
portion of their match so I like MBL on
that one by score plus three all right
well let's move on to the match that
happens just a day later it'll have some
Russian on Russian action the PG version
Robert don't get your mind over there
tell us what you see going on here with
cardiac inand nepo facing off well this
is definitely the most difficult one to
predict I know this Sergei cardiac it is
a blitz legend we just saw him dominate
in st. Louis in the grand chest
but nepo is fierce in the bullet portion
that match myself Kuryakin winning that
one probably squeaking by with a very
close match all right well a few days
later we then have the American on
American action this time not the Spring
Break edition again Robert sorry to
disappoint but the Nakamura versus
Caruana edition what's gonna happen here
well I think Nakamura and blow him out
of the water he completely dominates
Fabiano in quick chest back in st. Louis
Fabiana had some great positions there's
one game in particular with two
dominating nights over two horrible
bishops and a car won anyway so I see
Nakamura just completely blowing Carwin
out of the water all right well the last
match will then be on November 21st with
the world champion taking on Wesley so
the third Americans still left in the
speeches championship what do you got
here
well was ystos hit a slump in 2017 and
he's never beaten magnus carlsen a class
VII game of chess I know this is speed
chess but Magnus Carlsen will continue
his great streak against was he so and
dominate him in this match as well all
right well there you have it this is the
bracket as it remains everybody you see
we have just broken down every matchup
we know all of you will be marking your
calendars with the first match coming up
on October 23rd Robert we will see you
on November 21st flying alongside me as
my partner as we commentate on Magnus
Carlsen versus Wesley cell ding li Ren
has had a great 2017 but perhaps no
victory finer than this one over Gujrati
visit from the World Cup
tell everybody what the Chinese played
here yeah I really nice move white now
plays pawn to d5 and the reason this
move is such a fantastic move is that
this Square is protected by five black
pieces but the real reason for this move
is to open up the bishop on b2 so when
black captures on d5 which he has to do
white can now play Bishop takes f6 and
this allows the Queen entrance into h7 a
very nasty idea but still a beautiful
move from ding there speaking of
beautiful moves vu hung she had a few of
them against the Norwegian during the
World Cup
he sent the world champion packing and
this game here was the one that did it
tell everybody the brilliant sacrifice
he played yeah I mean this was really
nice in this position black played
Bishop takes H free and this is the way
you beat world champions you have to
show no fear and go straight for their
King and after pawn takes H free the
Queen comes into the attack White has to
defend H 2 was something like Knight to
f1 which he played but the whole point
of this attack is the ongoing pressure
that black has and this should we say
gamble paid off and boo went on to win a
great game he absolutely did and
speaking of great games also again from
the World Cup Pharaoh say I've had a
brilliant win here as black over Maxime
Raj Dean totally buddy what he shocked
the world with in this position yeah
he's got a bit of an attack here because
the white King is a little bit weak but
he now plays porn
free and this allows the Queen into f2
but it also sacrifices to pieces not one
but two white plays Bishop takes d5 the
Queen does come into f2 only one move
for whites Queen f1 and now King to h2
and we see the real point of this idea
blacks Bishop comes into the attack
Bishop to g5 with the idea of going
Bishop to f4 checkmate
but also given up a piece with checks so
Bishop takes c6 the King moves and in
this position the only way to stop
checkmates is for white to give up the
Queen so something like Queen takes III
but a position is very easily winning
for black I mean I think the only person
who might fluff this one up is mr.
Williams if I was playing a mr. Feingold
but okay Danny let's not go there I
still got some shakes about that one
looking back at the big news stories
from September Peter doggers is here to
tell us about one very long very
important event that was held in Tbilisi
of course we're talking about the World
Cup and any yeah in a tournament that
lasted for more than three weeks and
started with 128 players Levon Aronian
eventually emerged as the winner on his
way to victory he beat the likes of -
Vizzini von Schuch and Maxime for Sheila
Graf in an epic semi-final which was
also a qualifier for the candidates
Aronian defeated the Frenchman in the
ultimate Armageddon game and this he
became the first player ever to win two
World Cups because 12 years ago in
kuntum Sisk he was also the winner it
was a great month for iranian who got
married three days after the World Cup
but it was also a great year for a
runyan so far because before this event
he also won the st. Louis rabid and
blitz the Norway chess and the Greenwich
s tournament meanwhile ding near-end who
lost her Iranian in the final also had a
great tournament of course by beating
Wesley so in the semi-final he became
the first ever Chinese grandmother to
qualify for the candidates
there were really only two blunders that
stood out to us from the last month of
play we're gonna start with Vladimir
Kramnik big defeat against James tar
Shawn from the chest calm Isle of Man
international you were there in person
Simon and so you saw this tactic as what
was happening tell everybody how Kramnik
collapsed here yeah this is amazing I
mean a brilliant result for Tarjan and
in this position black is certainly a
bit better and he plays now Bishop to f3
trying to exchange that LightSquared
bishop soft but simply forgetting that
white can take on f3 and if cranek now
continues with his normal idea the idea
he planned of Queen takes f1 white just
has Bishop e2 trapping the Queen and
it's really as simple as that so white
gained a very good position a winning
position after this Bishop takes F free
move we can see a couple of things
Knights hg free and here bishop to f2
the last move where whites to bishops
far outweigh blacks works so were a very
nice victory for Tarjan but a big
blunder from cramming there but speaking
of big blunders not sure if you knew
this was gonna be our last pick but your
biggest blunder was probably just a
decision to show up against Ben Feingold
I'm gonna take everybody through the
last game of this match against Ben
where you started with Harry then you
played Airy you're an a pawn Airy and
then you just I mean I'm not sure if you
even saw the final blunder coming Ben
knew you were on Full Tilt he opens the
center quickly and did you even see that
rook h2 was met by Queen e5 blundering
you're Brooke or what was going through
your head at this point um you really
want to know what's going through my
head at this point you probably don't
Danny you've probably done I realized
I'd lost the match and and I didn't see
Queen e5 my position is falling apart
everything was falling apart I felt like
my life was falling apart and this is
probably I saw there's a big thread on
reddit about this may be one of the
worst games of grandmasters ever played
so I've got some I've done something
with my life now Danny so yeah not the
best
it's everybody's favorite segment let's
take a look back at the best moments
from the last month of chess and Anna
you go first starting at number three is
Bingley rands qualification to the
candidates tournament he is the first
Chinese player to ever do so will he be
the first Chinese world champion he's
got it with the candidates first before
he could play Magnus Carlsen in a match
but we'll see
speaking of Carlsen he takes our number
two spot ana for winning the chest comm
isle of man international with a 2,900
performance seven and a half out of nine
and it's his first classical tournament
victory in 14 months
but an even bigger victory goes to Levin
Aronian for winning the Fida World Cup
and two days later getting married to
Ariane Kelly back again to tell us how
the chess calm Isle of Man international
finish with Carlson journeying to the
island is Peter Dockers yeah absolutely
Martin is game for the first time to
Isle of Man he saw a very strong field
and he conquered with Senna half out of
nine Carlson won his first tournament in
14 months and was very happy with his
play it was convincing enough that a
quick draw with Hikaru Nakamura in the
final round secured him to 50,000 pound
first prize on top of his starting fee
one story line was that Carlson came to
Isle of Man only with his girlfriend
they were together at the informal
opening ceremony she visited the
tournament later on and she was also at
the closing ceremony Carlson gave a very
good speech there I must say and at the
very end after thinking a lot of people
including the sponsors especially
thanked her so he showed himself to be a
true gentleman the other story was about
Vladimir Kramnik who is in a fight with
Fabiano Caruana and Wesley so for two
ratings posts to the candidates kramnik
made things very difficult for himself
by losing to Khurana in the first round
but then also to 65 year-old Jim DeYoung
and then he was helped to withdraw by
Lawrence Trent Kramnik is only a few
weeks to make up for the lost round when
you're dropping games to Lawrence Trent
you know you're in trouble we'll see a
crane that can recover
and finally I'd like to thank Cygnus
over there who has made this very
enjoyable magnus carlsen giving credit
where credit is due Anna but what is the
full story of his relationship with Miss
Larson Duvall champion changed his
relationship status on facebook on the
14th of February this year and then went
to the chest dot-com Isle of Man
International together with Cena this is
the first event that they traveled
together and Magnus also posted a selfie
about it on his Instagram clearly shows
that the achievement is thanks to Cena
on to the worst things that happened in
the chess world from the last month of
play we're gonna give number 3 - the
collective world's elite Anna because
Magnus Carlsen Vladimir Kramnik and
Hikaru Nakamura were all sent packing in
round 3 of the World Cup and they
disappointed chess fans by not being in
Tbilisi there at the end another elite
player that was knocked out is Vishy
Anand he lost to Anton kovalyov who gets
our second place because of the short
skate controversy that was certainly not
good for neither the player nor fear nor
the chess community no one gets their
opening spot speaking of things that
weren't necessarily good for the chess
community we're gonna give it to the
social media the world of chess social
media for going on a made-up witch-hunt
against the pairing system at the Isle
of Man accusing manipulation of hope on
playing several female players in a row
it was fake news even though Yifan never
said anything publicly was not upset
about it at all and a good reminder to
not assume there's a story where there
really isn't one Fabiano Caruana played
Vladimir Kramnik in the first round of
the chess calm Isle of Man international
that's because of a random pairings
lottery that I still don't know do
people want this system or not Mike well
Danny and made people tuned in they were
all in the same score group after all
you know the purists in the Internet
crowd would revile any new innovation
Under the Sun but
sure many things more exciting and just
the luck of the drawers what created all
that controversy sticking with the isle
of man James Tarr Sean after 30 years
off to be a librarian has come back
strong he beat two world champions in
one tournament what would his career
ceiling have been if he hadn't quit to
going to the media art it's a great
question Mike you know he was super
strong in his prime and apparently he's
super strong now I could totally have
seen him having a gelfand maybe a von
shut type career not quite world
champion level but hanging around the
top 10 20 for years and years
we're not leaving the aisle just yet
because I got one more hard-hitting
question who's more to blame for the
final round Judd between Magnus Carlsen
and Nakara Nakamura little bit of both I
mean first of all Hikaru for having a
limited enough opening repertoire for
Carlsen to have planned out this
repetition but of course Carlsen is the
one that really engineered it
maybe Peter Highness to blame I think
Peter Heine is the one that really got
Magnus is here told him to go for the
draw
sticking with DiCaro for a second now he
just spoke at the Forbes 30 under 30
conference what do you think his public
speaking rating is maybe twenty to
twenty three hundred to caro would
probably rank himself higher and I'll at
least say I do enjoy listening to him
more than some other top players in the
world but I got another question to
bring you back to the real buzz on chess
comm Mike how have you not played a game
of four player Chelsea out I mean do you
want my productivity to go down to zero
I've played too many games of risk in my
life to know that when the other three
team up against you it's no fun and I'm
kind of having some flashbacks there
Danny and finally a new documentary
chronicles the Karpov Korchnoi matches
how do you plan to watch those obviously
getting my Flay favorite flavors of
randomly colored yellows and debating
Kasparov Putin theories with the rest of
the room
[Music]